[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
happy almost Friday
yeah we can hang on one more day if we
just believe
especially if it's red meat Thursday
[Music]
you love
me Thursday because you agree with us
yeah kiss my ass if you don't like these
politics oh that's because y'all were
little yeah
[Applause]
I tell Gene could you just put something
together and that's what he does
sick little boy
Yeah it's red meat Thursday when we tell
you what you already knew to be true and
everyone who disagrees can go f
themselves to quote Dana Perino
tonight's red meat leftists are ugly I
know you knew that already you've seen
The View
it begins with a new artificial
intelligence study out of Denmark which
is a country I believe
turns out AI can now predict a person's
political leanings with 61 accuracy and
it's based solely on their face
it's far more accurate than the old
method which was based on ass size
but when they judge the facial features
used to make these political predictions
they found something else the right
Wingers were way hotter
yeah yeah yeah but with some notable
exceptions of course
he brought down the Curve
but now here's the boring part Danish
scientists those are the kind with
cheese or fruit filling they fed 3 200
photos of political candidates into the
ATI AI tool to assess their emotional
state and after the analysis they found
that 80 percent displayed a happy
expression but behind those happy faces
were conservative female politicians who
looked happier and more attractive than
liberals now reasons for this happiness
abound you're not surrounded by gloom
and doom and it's easier to walk in
heels without cloven hooves
oh
and I'm sure the bathing helps but the
studies authors note that such a finding
makes sense because previous research
has also highlighted highlighted this
link between attractiveness and
conservatism
which means it's a it's time for a
gratuitous shot of Dana Perino Isn't She
Lovely yeah and that's without makeup
here she is with makeup
so why are uh conservatives so hot what
could be the reason for this are liberal
women really uglier than conservative
women and is that why they still wear
useless masks when driving alone in
their tiny cars
or could it be due to the adopting an
ideology of hopelessness based on the
unfixable nature of an evil society and
that begets their anger which ultimately
undermines their natural good looks it's
also hard to embrace Beauty when those
around you call any attention that you
receive from your beauty a form of
objectification the male gaze and so if
they can't find beauty in the world they
denounce their own and destroy it with
hair dye piercings and cases of cheap
frozen pizza
this could explain all those mug shots
of female antifa members when we talk
about an ugly Bunch but they weren't
always this way here they are before
they embraced leftist Dogma
thank God I dumped them before they
discovered MSNBC
so rather than look hot they try to
approximate the opposite as a political
statement and it's one you wouldn't want
to sit next to on a bus meanwhile the
study also found that left-leaning men
had more neutral faces than conservative
men meaning they didn't look as happy
but I guess it's hard to look happy
after they remove your balls
seriously how happy can you be if your
wife forces you to go to drag queen
Story Hour at the library you're just a
spineless sack of low testosterone and
lack the upper body strength that break
free and run away so left-leaning men
are better at hiding their emotions
apparently they've got better poker
faces which makes sense a good con man
never lets the mark know how he really
feels and you get a lot of practice
lying if you're a man who claims to be a
liberal you gotta lie all the time oh
please yes dye your hair purple to
commemorate Juneteenth I agree Sarah
Silverman she's really funny
wow this kale is delicious
so if you lie and lie it makes sense
that your face maintains an ominous
paralysis
yeah he kind of always looks like he's
facing somebody holding up a crucifix
but he's just been lying the whole time
so what does this mean for the future if
AI is this good at telling the
difference between a liberal and a
conservative based on a single photo
then what's next knowing the left
they'll probably use this technology to
keep conservatives under surveillance
most journalists are already eager to
dig through the personal life of anyone
who criticizes a Democrat they enjoy
canceling people who stand in their way
of a progressive but holy miserable
Society so what's next perhaps we just
identify the happy people and let Skynet
do the rest
[Music]
oh
there he is what's welcome tonight yes
she's the mom who still gets asked to
the prom Fox News anchor Julie Bandera
[Applause]
he Frist and cuffed hundreds sometimes
as a police officer former NYPD
inspector and attorney Paul Morrow
geez cheerful only when she's giving you
an earful Fox News contributor captive
and his fanny pack sleep seven my
massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion tyrant
truly it is quite obvious that you're
far better looking than anyone on CNN or
MSNBC but that's a low bar they're all
very homely people male female and those
in between do you buy the science I do
actually if you look at conservatives
across the border I mean I would say
it's not bored not just across the board
down across the border because they live
here now but no if you look across the
board and you look at conservatives
overall they are less angry and if
you're less angry you're more attractive
and there is a lot of scowling coming
from the left and a lot of angry
liberals and that does make them ugly I
do believe that it makes men more
attractive to you identify as what a
conservative I don't know I changed my
mind a lot right now I'm uh I'm a forest
pygmy so what's your excuse I don't know
I'm uh I find that uh uh yeah being
happy just makes you uh better looking
and more you feel better now than when
you started at Fox oh really which I
think means you've become more
conservative since you started or maybe
I was miserable back then possibly I
think you can find people who would say
that no but you actually have improved
with age that's not very common yeah I
mean he's accepting the whole pygmy
thing I'm proud of him
yes that's true
he normally wouldn't say he was a pygmy
and he just had this great moment where
he just said it in passing no one we
should all clap for him we should be
proud
it's not easy
not easy
this is the smallest of anything I
applied a therapist but your orthopedic
shoes probably help with that these are
not orthopedic shoes these are Prada
look at that huh for the height impaired
pick me
here all right Paul you've got a fairly
good Poker Face what do you do this uh
this stuff finding that like liberal men
have better poker faces isn't it because
they have to like agree and lie all the
time I'm gonna tell you why I agree with
this study because consider the fact
that AI was essentially constructed by a
whole slew of soy boys out in Silicon
Valley right and it still went
conservatives right you know that
there's got to be something to it and I
think the clue is embedded in the in the
terminology right if you take
Progressive versus conservative
conservatives they want to hang on to
the good stuff right they're kind of
saying to themselves you know what
there's a lot that works here America is
imperfect but and capitalism democracy
imperfect but it's better than anything
else we've come up with let's hang on to
it progressives the idea is we're going
someplace else we're going to Shangri-La
there's a city on a hill we're going to
get there you never going to get there
and so it's embedded right in ideology
that you're always going to be
dissatisfied it's like taking a very
long car ride with apparently a bunch of
very cranky ugly women and we've all
been through those you know I know your
college Years and you know it's not
really an ex pleasant experience no it
is and it isn't but I do think like if
you if you believe there's no there's
nothing positive in life then all you're
going to do is ex it's going to come out
of your pores and they'll never let that
go because that's the business model and
they can to be out of jobs exactly the
activist face belongs in the activist
class cat and they can't let it go or
they'd be out on their ass
see that there was a rhyme
how you doing there cat I'm okay yeah
that's good that's good yeah yeah I
don't buy any of this why
not well because you have to be happy
for people who want to bang you my life
doesn't make any sense
it's got a point yeah wait are you
saying you're miserable today I'm well I
mean just like I don't think I give off
a sunshiny Vibe yeah
yeah to me because it's like now
conservatives like biased AI yeah we did
weeks on like AI is woke and now that it
tells you you're hot that it's all over
yeah that's human nature once you get a
compliment you forget about everything
else maybe I also just I don't think you
can tell if someone's hot based on a
picture there's so many times I thought
someone is hot and then I hear them talk
and I'm like
right yes
yes you are right thank you I thought so
yes Tyrus do you agree with Kat that
this is BS
yes for different reasons uh
I looked at a lot of those photos and I
just saw a lot of
unhappy dudes you know and that's not a
Democratic Republic thing that's a
married guy thing
I know the look The Empty the soulless
look in the eyes because it's the 50th
time they took the same damn picture
over and over again that's not your real
smile where's the real smile that's the
smile you use with the like it's
just it's never ending and the guy
always has the same look
yeah
and that's not a Republican or a
Democrat thing that's a
I I I'm stuck fellas
check on me and that's and if you look
at those pictures across the board is
this it's liberal dudes because dudes we
make that mistake you know they'll meet
a woman and she'll be like I'm in
astronomy and and really ridiculous uh
reparations and stuff and you'll be like
yeah me too yeah and he will follow and
he will take that trail he will go on
that journey and then he gets what he
thought he wanted now he's stuck and
there's someone there to take a picture
to send all your friends and they all
say the same thing
you need help bro that would be the
funniest Tinder bio ever though I'm into
astrology and reparations yeah and to do
some dude somewhere will be like me too
cat
okay so if you're into astrology and
reparations you would only give
reparations to like Virgos yeah that's
how you'd combine the two but but a dumb
guy would be like yeah I agree yeah
absolutely well played I've been waiting
for so much my whole life but it's hard
for women like I honestly I was going to
do this on the monologue but we couldn't
do it to show the before and after
pictures of people of people who go woke
like you see this they're young
beautiful girls that deliberately
destroy the way they look for a couple
of reasons one they are they're told by
their peers in college that beauty is
objectification that it's not real no
it's real little kids find people
attractive you know they they you they
develop crushes in first grade that
ain't social that's just real and so you
have all these young people who believe
that ugly like that that there's no
truth in Beauty and there is truth in
Beauty hate to tell you
and it's usually the ugly people that
talk them into doing it yes
ugly people need friends yeah
yes join us yeah nothing looks good like
shaving down the middle of your head
sweetheart yeah that's the look
but you never see the ones tell them to
do it they have the same haircut exactly
all right we got to move on hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else